[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un là-bas regarde ça bien
présentant axel la dernière
protection militaire avec reconnaissance faciale
des systèmes d'armes à bord et
des capacités d'appariement du propriétaire c'est maintenant jumelé le
gâteau est un certain contrôle de l'ensemble du
projet que
vous voulez jouer d'accord allons-y
je  je veux te montrer quelque chose bonjour
écoute parler ouais reste secoué un garçon
fais tu donc tout ce que j'ai dit mais quelqu'un a
dépensé beaucoup d'argent pour eux ils doivent
village avant lui je ne pense pas que son
propriétaire mérite de le récupérer
j'ai besoin de  sais ce qu'il fait il
évolue bien au-delà des attentes c'est
mon chien je veux qu'il revienne
lancez les médicaments
allez vous avez besoin de notre aide
ce que vous devriez faire est de le rendre
sent les choses
vous envoyer le nouvel emplacement emménager pour
récupérer
[Musique]
ou vous perdre ensemble
vous